hello this is the second film
uh now talking about the book he was our
certification
for any of you who are around the world
and wish to do the certification I've
already explained that you don't have to
be any warmer
trained student you may have copied
films books or you may have been on a
seminar with an Obama teacher and you
just favor the weapons
now looking on the website you may think
that there isn't a great deal being
asked for the
levels of bookwaza
but what myself and what side of Sensei
wanted me to give him my word for two
was
how well you're doing them you know how
many how perfect do you know them how
many
incorrections have you got within
yourself that you can't see
so please read fully everything on the
website and
you could electronically send the forms
back to me filled in and then I'll
assess them and get back to you
if you're in
Europe or and can get to one of my days
where I'm going to be testing people for
boogie waza that's uh
obviously the best way but I realize
with the costs and everything nowadays
this is difficult so I'm what I'm doing
I'm allowing you to send me
a film
I need a film showing you from the front
and also
at the side
um it doesn't have to be a
Direct
angle of the side it can be slightly off
depending on where you're doing them
but I do want to see
um
how you perform your body at the side as
well as from the front
it in some cases people will be able to
do more than one level if they've been
Obama trained for a long time
and you can then do them cathetic
consecutively
in a short period
but you will only send me one at a time
I will not accept like three films or
three levels at once just because the
person feels they're good enough
I will determine that and tell you when
you can apply or send me the next one
I hope you understand that I'm not
trying to be difficult I'm trying to be
precise
I may not be the best if I'm a teacher
out there in the world I have no idea
I'm only as good as I am and I do my
best
I gave my word to say to Sensei that I
would keep his weapons and those senses
weapons safe
now
they seem very few things being asked
especially in the first one
but it's preciseness
and this I think most people will find
that they are a weak in some areas
I'd like to just tell you the format
if it's in front of me we will go
through it and I will be making notes
on the seventh February for pretend that
um
I'm not happy with your third and your
sixth early I will make a note of that
but I shall watch you do it either on
film or
the time physically you will do three of
each suburi whether it's with Ken or Joe
you would do three of each
if yoga only have one camera
then you will need to do three from the
front and the take three from the side
so you'll be doing six
I will make a note
and if I don't think that you if you're
physically in front of me after you've
done the full
criteria for level one
I will then tell you what I don't see
correct and if
we can spend time correcting it and you
correct it then you will get the level
certificate
if you cannot correct it to my
satisfaction
you will go away and come back to me
when you feel that it's been corrected
however months it may be
um
payment will be at the beginning
of the before I test you
in film or physically
and that fee will last for a period of
12 months
after that period I'm afraid you'll have
to pay again
it's not designed many people might
comment that oh it's a money making
machine it's not it's purely that I gave
my word to cytosensei and it's a great
burden but I must carry it out to his
wishes
it takes time it will take between
individually F5 people are on the
seminar
just for the book he was a seminar
then it will take at least an hour to an
hour and a half
if I individually check each person
and correct them if it's straightforward
and I see no problems then it shouldn't
take so long at all perhaps 30 minutes
this is all time that it costs me and it
cost me to hire the hall
post the certificate certificates
and I'm not trying to justify the cost
I'm just trying to say that it's not
done for money is done because I want
senses and oh senses weapons to shine
out
in the world and for those who take part
and know that they've
passed my scrutiny what's that and and
it's helped sharpen their weapons
if you need more information please get
in touch with me
every level will be done the same
I will test you
if it's a film I should sit here go
through it in exactly the same way check
the front check the side of you I shall
make notes and I shall send you back or
we'll have a zoom meeting or some form
of interaction physically where I go
through the points once I've sent you of
them back electronically
we'll go through the points so that you
know exactly what you have to improve on
anywhere that you are in the world
situated
and as I said before you can be just an
individual who likes doing the weapons
but you would like to know that you're
doing them correctly
you can test at first queue but you will
not receive them until you receive first
down from your own organization or
wherever you are in the world
um
to be tested because they're they're
downgrade certification but first queues
can pay and obtain the test
and we can help by giving you the
corrections so that you can work towards
perfecting them
and then when you get your first down
wherever you may be in the world
and your certification will go along
with that downgrade they don't have to
run in line like I have a fourth down
applied to me
and he'll will he will have to still
take the first level
and everybody will have to nobody can
jump and nobody as I say can send them
all in one go however good they think
they are and this must be a methodical
precise
certification
and I thank you for for listening to me
taking part and if you need any more
information
get back to me all the details on the
website I hope to hear from you soon
thank you